allons plus loin qui continue avec notre
grand débat zoom ce soir sur les
annonces du jour pour le monde de la
culture
à l'issue de sa rencontre avec les
acteurs du secteur roselyne bachelot a
fait 3 annonce 20 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour l'emploi artistique
accès au droit maternité et maladie pour
les intermittents qui n'auraient pas
fait assez d'heures fonds d'urgence
abondé de 10 millions d'euros
est-ce que ça suffira à apaiser la
colère des intermittents qui occupe
toujours plusieurs théâtres du pays
depuis quelques jours c'est loin d'être
certain parce que leur détermination
elle est sans faille c'est ce qu'ont pu
constater nos journaliste sandra
cerqueira et gaspard flamands qui se
sont rendus devant le théâtre de l'odéon
à paris
[Musique]
chaque jour à 14 heures les occupants
organise l'agora du théâtre de l'odéon
les lieux décide
[Musique]
une semaine d'occupation est un
mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur dans
les théâtres de france
à l'intérieur la mobilisation se
structure pour que la contestation
deviennent nationale mise en place de
commissions organisation d'assemblée
générale les intermittents à l'image de
louise se disent déterminés à rester
tant que les réponses du gouvernement
manqueront la visite de roselyne
bachelot le week-end dernier ne les a
pas rassurés nous a donné plein de
belles paroles un soutien théorique
voilà c'était très joli mais ça nous
apporte est absolument rien ils
réclament le prolongement de l'année
blanche pour les intermittents qui n'ont
pas pu faire leur heure à cause des
fermetures sans prolongation un tiers
d'entre eux se retrouveraient sans
revenu fin août une situation
inacceptable pour valérie occupantes de
la première heure
[Musique]
l'année blanche ça fait que j'ai mille
quatre cent balles par man donc
effectivement ça je paye mon loyer parce
que j'ai la chance d'avoir un look très
petit mais il ya énormément de gens qui
ont été les autres principales
revendications la réouverture des lieux
culturels au public avec des dispositifs
adaptés et le retrait de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
ce que nous demandons pour les
travailleurs précaires du spectacle
c'est évidemment la même chose quand on
est extra hôtelier saisonniers guide
conférencier et et toutes sortes de
métiers qui sont touchés aussi par des
interdictions et ont été oubliés par les
mesures du gouvernement à part des
aumônes tous l'assurent ils ne sont pas
là que pour le monde de la culture
solidaires aussi de ceux qu'ils
appellent les intermittents de l'emploi
les précaires des autres secteurs qui se
retrouvent sans aucune aide à cause de
la crise sanitaire première manche avec
nous ce soir pour le grand débat daele
pl jean michel ribes bienvenue vous êtes
un auteur dramatique metteur en scène
cinéaste acteur vous diriger le théâtre
du rond point
depuis près de 20 ans on pouvait garder
le chapeau ya pas de problème face avoue
laurent hénard bienvenu vous êtes
président du mouvement radical ancien
adjoint à la culture du maire de nancy
et vous avez présidé pendant 13 ans la
réunion des opéras de france avec nous
également mais à distance sylvie robert
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
d'ille et vilaine vice présidente de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication et vous êtes
l'ancienne directrice des relations
publiques du théâtre national de
bretagne
françoise benhamou est également avec
nos bienvenue vous êtes professeur
d'économie à l'université sorbonne-paris
nord membre du cercle des économistes
et vous êtes spécialiste de l'économie
de la culture des médias et du numérique
merci infiniment à tous les quatre
d'être avec nous jean michel ribes vous
les avez entendus les annonces de
roselyne bachelot je les rappelle
rapidement 20 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour l'emploi artistique
accès au droit maternité maladie pour
les intermittents qui n'auraient pas
fait assez d'heures et fonds d'urgence
abondé de 10 millions d'euros qui passe
donc à 17 millions d'euros
vous attendiez plus non mais c'est très
bien et on est un des rares pays qui
fait ça c'est insuffisant bien sûr mais
on le sait le problème n'est pas là on
la culture
de considération c'est comme si un
écrivain on lisait vous inquiétez pas on
vous paie votre rencontre et votre
ordinateur vous faites votre papier ce
cas mais on est des trappes à votre lit
parce que s'il était dite et on va le
passer la main en main et ça fait mal
c'est ça qui va pas je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une une approche de
la pandémie du gouvernement qui me
semblent sensées enfin celle qu'elle est
territorialisées eh bien on ne tue pas
croire dans le finistère c'est
tranquille voilà on dit bon il n'y a pas
les mêmes traitements que je sais pas
dans les alpes-maritimes dans l'île de
france eh bien nous les théâtres on est
con et le finistère on est vert il n'y a
pas eu un seul klaus terre etc
je dis ça il faut bien savoir qu'aucune
personne de la culture en particulier du
monde du spectacle vivant ne souhaite
transmettre le virus à qui que ce soit
on est la vie on n'est pas la mort mais
d'un autre côté on apporte aussi ses
soutiens fédérations espèce d'ailleurs
aux gens qui sont quand même très
dépressif et ça je sais pas pourquoi on
veut pas arriver à 35 en considération
on est un peu aussi des réanimateurs et
nous tout cela on est complètement à
genoux
laurent hénart c'est vrai qu'on est un
peu de mal à comprendre hier le sénateur
communiste ou au lit elle se disait dans
l'hémicycle et il interpellait roselyne
bachelot on entendra tout à leur disait
on est dans un siège toutes les semaines
un siège sur trois pourquoi avons nous
le droit de 6 g pourquoi avons nous le
droit de nous réunir et pas dans un
théâtre un peu de mal à comprendre
oui ça c'est enfin très objectivement
c'est un effet de manche un peu facile
quand même ça il faut bien que l'on sait
surtout qui a été moins drôle que ce que
vous faites dans la serre mais ça que je
fais plus rien mais je ne suis plus
député camille de clusters au sénat
alors qu'il sèche ou si il y en a eu non
mes taxes avec qui on a eu en plus oui
avait ya longtemps mais je pense que
c'est enfin honnêtement c'est pas le
sujet parce que de toute façon un
confinement forcément emporte une
décision arbitraire un moment donné vous
fermer certaines choses qui sont à des
lisières d'autres choses que vous
laisser ouvertes et
je pense que le sujet c'est surtout
qu'avec la vaccination avec le
développement des tests jeu depuis le
début depuis le mois de novembre depuis
le début du 2ème confinement je milite
pour qu'on avance rapidement sur ce
sujet de passes sanitaires pourquoi
parce que la vaccination la sérologie
aussi de ceux qui ont déjà été malade et
qui donc ont des anticorps elle peut
être consignées sur un petit livret
maintenant qu'on a des tests salivaires
dont on a un résultat en dix minutes
pour ceux qui n'ont pas le vaccin qui
n'ont pas d'anticorps on peut faire le
test avant d'entrer dans la salle pour
vous ce sera la solution pour l'été non
seulement en séries en attendant mais
c'est ça devrait déjà être fait 20 juin
en israël je suis désolé ça fonctionne
oui les pays nordiques le font via ces
quelques jeunes auraient pu réfléchir
mettre en place avant et on a le même
sujet qu'avec la vaccination comme y
avait des français qui étaient
réfractaires à la vaccination
on a ralenti la vaccination pour tout le
monde puis quand on a vu qu'une bonne
partie des français qui voulaient être
vaccinés commencé à râler alors là on a
accéléré la vaccination
et là on retrouve le même sujet si vous
voulez vous avez des personnes qui ont
peur de ce pass sanitaire qui est un
élément d'information qu'on peut
sécuriser sur le plan internet et
fichiers et qui permettrait de rouvrir
beaucoup plus vite les lieux l argent du
cirque ensuite on va vous dire on va
vous dire qu'on est en train de confiner
certains départements peut-être demain
l'île de france et que dans un moment où
le quart des départements pourraient
être confinées c'est peut-être pas le
moment d'ouvrir c'est ça la réponse
qu'ils allaient me servais d'accord
parce que si tous le monde étaient
vaccinés oui 6ème et un flot de enfin
grande partie de la population active là
ça veut dire que seuls les gens vaccinés
peuvent aller au théâtre c'est parce que
j'ai dit si c'est parce que j'ai dit ce
que j'ai dit c'est que soit vous avez
quelqu'un qui est vaccinée ou qui a des
antidotes cas des antilles corps par non
parce qu'il a été malade et celui là
c'est qu'on s'est mis ses consignes et
dans son smartphone avec un dossier avec
un certificat quelque chose soit vous
n'avez pas le vaccin parce que vous
n'avez pas voulu le faire par exemple et
on vous fait un test est aujourd'hui
déteste moi je suis allé voir dans les
écoles les tests qui sont mis en place
de manière quand même importante c'est
plusieurs centaines de milliers de tests
qui ont été réalisés ça fonctionne très
bien vous allez résultat en dix ou
quinze mille est là donc on pourrait
soit par le test soit par un pass
sanitaire clarifier tout ça nous avons
deux autres intervenantes qui attendent
patiemment françoise benhamou
le poids économique de la culture en
france est quand même assez important
d'où aussi la surprise de voir un
gouvernement qui ne qui tarde quand même
à faire quelque chose au-delà des aides
mais pour leur permettre de rouvrir
on a du mal à comprendre c'est étonnant
pas c'est paradoxal vu le poids
économique de la culture dans le pays
le point godwin d'un cube qui est à peu
près deuxième de 3% du pib mais ce sont
650 mille emplois ce qui est beaucoup
c'est évidemment un point extrêmement
important à prendre en compte pour le
gouvernement mais il est clair que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et valent
largement au delà de l'économie c'est à
dire que vous avez à la fois une faible
conscience je trouve de la part de nos
gouvernants sans doute que de ce point
économie justement de ce que représente
la culture à la fois directement et sans
doute indirectement aussi et puis vous
avez une immense crise de confiance qui
a un effet aujourd'hui de contamination
dans le secteur je pense que ça va pas
s'arrêter là et qu'il ya un risque qu'on
change de braquet c'est je pense qu'il
est absolument indispensable je rejoins
le jean michel ribes là-dessus d'avoir
un traitement fin de la question est de
passer à une autre manière de considérer
les lieux culturels les lieux culturels
ne sont pas tous dans la même situation
on aurait pu ouvrir les musées depuis
très longtemps par exemple pourquoi
traiter la culture de manière
monolithique et quant au théâtre
sans doute certains théâtres peuvent-ils
ouvrir soit parce qu'ils sont situés
dans une dans une région où cela est
possible
soit parce que la salle est grande ce
soit pour d'autres raisons et certains
proposent d'ouvrir d'abord aux scolaires
et aux étudiants et de traiter par
exemple la venue des étudiants qui
auraient un travail à faire à
l'intérieur du théâtre comme un sage au
moment où les ces étudiants manquent de
stage et tout cela il faut il faut
absolument venir un traitement très fin
de la situation parce que c'est
absolument désespérant pour le monde
culturel ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est le vire au vert on voit qu'il ya
une rupture de confiance entre les
acteurs du monde de la culture s go
moment pourtant on peut difficilement
soupçonner roselyne bachelot de ne pas
aimer la culture ou emmanuel macron de
ne pas aimer la culture
vous y comprenez quelque chose vous
écoutez je pense que ça fait un an
maintenant que tout est à l'arrêt il ya
eu une petite ouverture en début
d'automne et on a bien vu d'ailleurs que
les protocoles sanitaires et est très
bien respectée dans ces salles quand on
allait au musée sur les réservations ou
alors dans des destinées main je pense
que il ya une confiance qui avait lieu
au départ et qui aujourd'hui
effectivement n'existe plus parce que il
ya un problème de de cohérence
il ya un problème de lassitude qui se
transforme aujourd'hui en colère et je
crois que les annonces qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui sont de bonnes
annonces on ne va pas regretter que 20
millions soit débloquée pour aller vers
les compagnies artistiques et notamment
les plus fragiles mais en attendaient de
la perspective et notamment la
perspective d'ouverture parce que on
n'ouvre pas à théâtre du jour au
lendemain et je crois que c'est ce
manque de perspectives commence à peser
vraiment dans notre société
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sent que ce
manque de culture au delà des impacts
économiques sociaux ont des est
forcément des a des conséquences
psychologiques voire psychique et je
crois que c'est ce qui donne du sens à
la vie et aujourd'hui notre société et
non seulement dans l'impatience mais les
acteurs ont envie de rouvrir jean michel
ribes on est aujourd'hui
oui faut arrêter ces notions ils ont
bien joué
le bac à sable au nombril et bien pas du
tout pas du tout aujourd'hui si vous
voulez moi ce que je réclame et
d'ailleurs nous annonce que le 25 mars
vous donne deux ronds-points un
directeur de théâtre on se réunir dans
leur plus grande le plus grand nombre
accompagné le virologue et accompagnés
de spécialistes de la santé c'est
simplement je voudrais dire que pourquoi
en nouant st est-ce qu'on peut analyser
les choses parce qu'on n'ait pas
simplement des danseurs ou là là là
dedans cela publie il s'amuse
non il faut simplement analysé ce qui se
passe
or ce qui se passe comme l'a dit madame
les conditions sanitaires des théâtres
sont extraordinairement respecté il n'y
a pas de danger
vous auriez prêt à rouvrir malgré les
interdictions ou pas alors j'aime rire
ça c'est une vraie question c'est une
question qui ne pourra laquelle je
pourrais répondre que c'est clairement
avec tout le monde mais on en parle on
en parle parce que il ya un moment si le
corps médical enfin en tout cas les
infectiologues virologues le conseil
scientifique je rappelle que monsieur
delfraissy a quand même dit j'ai jamais
demandé que ce soit fermée à partir de
ce moment là si tout le monde s'est dit
ça va on y va en effet peut-être qu'ils
ont un effet de souffle qui permettrait
en même temps peut-être de soulager aux
inondations parce que comme ça se serait
fait besoin de dire je vous dis
autorisée on ne prendra pas forcément
drôle de pays où là on l'a dégagera de
cette responsabilité
elle pourra continuer à dire qu'elle
aime les artistes coeur sur la main et
je je je pense que là y aurait en train
une preuve de deux choses 1 que c'est
pas dangereux et 2 que le public a envie
de ça je vous assure c'est pas pour mais
je vous assure je dis moi simplement à
londres le théâtre du rond point c'est
insensé
les lettres que les fans qu'on soit
parce que vous avez parlé de roselyne
bachelot elle a effectivement été
interpellé au sénat hier par l'élu
communiste pierre ouzeau liasses lors
des questions au gouvernement
et c'est quand même assez vigoureusement
que les ministres a voulu faire une mise
au point je voudrais qu'on écoute
quelques secondes et je vous fait réagir
après la pandémie continue à toucher
durement notre pays et l'europe
lieux culturels sont fermés les lieux de
spectacles sont fermés pour 85% des
citoyens européens parce que on mène en
europe une politique de prévention dans
aucun pays européen dans aucun pays du
monde
on ne soutient le monde de la culture
comme on le soutient dans notre pays
françoise benhamou c'est assez clair
quand même la ministre est en train de
dire à tous les intermittents tous les
acteurs de la culture en gros vous
n'êtes pas si mal loti que cela mais
c'est pas faux seins un soutien en un
soutien publi que économique
la question est est ce que les simples
peuvent s'ouvrir dans les conditions
tout à fait précise qui serait donné par
le corps médical et il ya eu des études
qui ont été faites y en a eu par exemple
en allemagne qui montrent effectivement
très clairement qu' il n'y a pas de
risque donc il faut ouvrir sans doute à
certaines conditions mais on peut pas
continuer comme ça parce que vous
cumulez plusieurs crises vous avez une
crise économique à proprement parler ex
crise sectorielle
vous avez aussi une crise
générationnelle c'est à dire les jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché de l'emploi
culturel et qui n'ont ni sage milieu où
aller etc
et puis vous avez cette crise à
proprement parler vraiment culturel à
cette fois ci c'est à dire nous avons
tous envie et besoin de culture et ça
n'est pas de l'ordre du caprice alors
que ce qui peut être fait soit fait
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas faire des
concerts debout serrés dans une seule
mais l etat chose que l'on peut faire et
donc je reviens sur cette idée de de
traitement une fin et par ailleurs c'est
vrai le gouvernement fait beaucoup de
choses il ay la dégager de l'argent dans
le cadre du plan de relance avec des
mesures à la fois spécifiques et des
mesures qui sont le sel de toute
l'économie mais qui peuvent s'appliquer
la culture donc on a les deux catégories
de mesures qui a eu l'année blanche pour
les intermittents qui sera évidemment
prolongé donc beaucoup de choses sont
faites mais ça n'est pas qu'une affaire
strictement économique ça veut dire que
jean bachelot prend le problème par le
mauvais bout quand elles rappellent aux
un temps aux intermittents qu'ils ont
quand même des aides que personne
d'autre n'a ailleurs en europe
non ce qu'elle dit c'est que
elle dit ça parce qu'elle district les
mesures sont prises pour que la
ressource ne disparaissent pas voyez ce
que je veux dire que tient un propos qui
est un propos de raison qui est de dire
parce que nous avons des aides parce que
nous prolongeons intermittence la
ressource artistique du pays et sa
ressource culturelle ne va pas
disparaître mais elle passe à côté je
pense d'un sentiment là je rejoins ce
qui a été dit du grand public des gens
pour qui aller au spectacle aller dans
un musée rencontrer des artistes ou voir
des oeuvres d'art c'est aussi
fondamental que faire du sport ou que
pour les enfants et les jeunes allaient
à l'école on a laissé les écoles
ouvertes
on a essayé de maintenir un peu de
pratique sportive même pendant le
premier confinement à l'époque j'étais
maire de nancy
il était beaucoup plus strictes que ce
qu'on a connu aujourd'hui mon avez vous
savez cette heure on devait aller courir
d'ailleurs c'était assez compliqué à
interpréter pour la police nationale et
la police municipale et est pour les
gens la culture c'est au moins aussi
important que ça voilà donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut prendre le
pouls de l'opinion
il ya la raison qui dit nous avons des
dispositifs des nous allons passer le
guet la ressource ne va pas disparaître
ont certes mais il ya aussi les
sentiments et puis et le sentiment
d'impatience et la deuxième elle
s'accroche et la légion l'année blanche
pourquoi ne pas l'annoncer pourquoi
tarde et elle annoncé alors qu'a priori
il n'y a pas le choix je pense que vous
auriez pour oui mais façon je pense que
je vais vous dire je pense que ça se
fera je veux dire le quoi qu'il en coûte
ayant j'ai la ligne directrice d'entrer
dans la crise sanitaire le quoi qu'il en
coûte prévaudra jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine et a rassuré les intermittents
tout de suite je je rejoins ce mois je
rejoins ce qui a été dit pour connaître
des intermittents puisque comme vous
l'avez dit je veux s'occuper d'opéra
s'occuper de thé âme
j'étais adjoint à la culture je me suis
je garde beaucoup d'amis évidemment dans
ce milieu merveilleux pour connais
beaucoup d'intermittents le sujet pour
eux c'est pas seulement la prolongation
du régime va plutôt de la séquence
blanche dans le régime
le sujet pour eux c'est un moment donné
quand est-ce qu'on retravaille enfin
mais ça oui mais quand est ce qu'à un
moment donné on retrouve le public était
second rang notre service zennaro sa
garantie la ressource
c'est vrai et c'est pas vrai ça garantit
la ressource financièrement oui je
laissais pas vrai parce qu'il ya des
gens qui craquent à des gens qui n'en
peuvent plus et ce serait je suis en
garde
la ressource de création la créativité
la culture c'est aussi une morale c'est
aussi le moral c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'ils diffusent c'est viscéral c'est ce
qu'ils ont aimé ce que vous avez au bout
ça diffuse sans arrêt que ce soit dans
les conversations dans dans partout ça
diffusent dans la société
vous l'aviez pour les écoles moi je me
suis un des professeurs des écoles quand
on a ouvert les écoles au mois de mai
fin quand le ministre blanc caire a pris
cette décision mais en tant qu'élu mot
j'y étais favorable
on avait beaucoup de professeurs des
écoles qui étaient heureux de retrouver
leur école donc j'ai laissé tous ses
métiers de l'humain et l'artiste mêmes
coeur d'un métier humain a besoin du
contact et bien rien il ya vraiment là
roselyne bachelot chauffer des âges a
quant elle dit tous les pays d'europe
font comme nous c'est le black out pour
les salles de spectacles etc
d'abord c'est pas vrai en espagne s'est
ouvert au luxembourg s'est ouvert et
alors si on était les seuls
la tour eiffel elle est nulle part
ailleurs est en france donc on peut
aussi inventer des choses parce que tout
le monde fait comme ça qu'on doit faire
comme ça on a été c'est un petit peu
notre devoir national
la révolution française on a été les
premiers à la faire en france
mais même la révolution doit donc se
dire que c'est pas un argument ça
alignons nous non inventons sylvie
robert oui bah écoutez moi je suis
d'accord avec les les
les propos de de jean michel ribes la dz
et économie que c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui on a il ya
une telle attendant notre pari que dans
notre pays que l'on peut imaginer des
protocoles qui sont extrêmement adaptée
à la faute territoire les directeurs de
lieux les plus professionnels et sont
extrêmement responsables ils l'ont
démontré
et je vais vous dire une chose je fais
partie de la mission d'information sur
les impacts comme byd notamment dans
dans le cadre de la culture et nous
avons auditionné monsieur flahaut
antoine flahaut épidémiologiste et qui
est donc en suisse alors ma question sur
les festivals en plein air par exemple
pour l'été prochain où là aussi
notamment aux jauges de boue il ya peu
de perspectives il a répondu que à
partir du moment où il ya les masques
comme c'est en plein air les études
récentes ont montré que il n'ya pas un
problème de contamination très
importante qui peut être à l'oeuvre dans
ces festivals
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut
vraiment aujourd'hui que la ministre
donne un peu d'espoir de perspectives et
surtout disent eh bien voilà on a besoin
que les lieux que les projets run est ce
parce que c'est c'est une réalité notre
pays en a besoin et tout le monde se met
au travail pour pour réouvrir et
j'ajoute au passage je vous dis allez
sur les territoriales tous les acteurs
seront au rendez vous il est responsable
culturel aussi et le professeur comme
sur ce même plateau avait dit il faut
rouvrir les salles du lac assal de ce
professeur commencé au téléphone il ya
deux jours il vient nous soutenir dans
cette réunion parce que c'est n'est pas
de lire et or c'est beau la culture on
en a besoin
c'est important oui d'accord ça tout le
monde le sait mais maintenant faut être
raisonnable et fois analysé analyse
comme autre chose et on analyse chaque
problème qui existe et à ce moment là
rationnellement médicalement
sanitairement on verra que la logique
sanitaire ne veut pas nous être
appliquée je voudrais qu'on se projette
un tout petit peu parce que l'inquiétude
ne porte pas uniquement sur le ici et
maintenant mais il porte aussi sur
l'après qu'ovide beaucoup d'angoissé
pour l'après qu'ovide la crise ne sera
pas terminée dès qu'on sera tous
vaccinés et des cons rouvrir à tous les
établissements c'est ce qu'a exprimé il
ya quelques jours
elisabeth bouchaud que vous connaissez
peut-être qui est directrice du théâtre
la reine blanche à paris elle était
notre invité dans le dernier numéro de
dialogue citoyen ya quelques jours
écoutons là je suis inquiète pour la
presse à vrai dire
parce que pour expliquer aux gens qui
nous écoutent la l'économie d'un théâtre
surtout d'un petit théâtre parisien
comme celui de la reine blanche ne
repose pas uniquement sur la billetterie
loin de là il repose aussi sur la vente
de dates de tournée de nos spectacles en
production et sa faudra que nous soyons
aider même après la réouverture
françoise benhamou c'est une réalité
c'est à dire que il y à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui les difficultés du moment
mais la préco vide il faudra absolument
que les aides continue oui au moins pour
un temps parce que c'est vrai que le
terrain c'est pas simplement aujourd'hui
ses terres seront programme pour un an
pour deux ans et c'est donc à deux
sujets il ya déjà le sujet des oeuvres
qui n'ont pas été joués et dont
certaines seront peut-être jamais joué
et puis d'autre part il ya l'équilibré
économique des salles deuxième chose
c'est à dire que si on rouvre mais avec
des jauges dégradé à ce moment là
l'équilibré économique sera plus
difficile à trouver
il faudra peut-être jouer encore plus
avec tout ce qu'ils ressentent dérivés
et toutes les difficultés ça peut
comporter
enfin troisième élément l'ensemble des
tournées qui constitue qui permet de
constituer l'equilibre sur une année et
par exemple voyez vous un festival comme
avignon et notamment le of how
extrêmement grande importance pour les
compagnies parce que c'est une sorte de
marché du théâtre qui va leur permettre
de trouver un certain nombre de dates et
de trouver leur équilibre
j'espère qu'avignon se tiendra cette
année si ça ne tenait pas ce serait une
catastrophe donc voilà la presse n'est
pas encore écrit loin s'en faut
elles sont nées très concrets m cette
cette aide elle devrait se poursuivre
sur combien de temps une fois que les
théâtres ont rouvert d'après vous
tout dépend de l'épidémie c'est à dire
que si leur inclination est vraiment
quasi générale
et qu'on arrive à sortir de l'épidémie à
ce moment là très vite on pourra en
trouver cet équilibre qui sont il faudra
sans doute quelques mois ou une année
si si ça continue de manière larvée avec
des stop and go là là je sais pas quoi
dire tellement la catastrophe serait de
vendre mais je n'y crois pas j'espère
qu'on va s'en sortir
à la faveur de la vaccination laurent et
la wii mais toute façon vous ce qui a
été dit est vrai dire que vous mettez un
temps à produire le spectacle vous le
donner dans votre théâtre et en plus il
tourne après ça fait une recette qui
rentre pas dans le dos le dans
l'économie générale de votre spectacle
donc je vois pas comment on ne pourra
pas avoir une saison complète avec des
dispositifs de soutien le temps que le
système serait amorce parce que
généralement vous produisez vous répétez
vous produisez dans votre théâtre et
après il tourne vous voyez tout ça quand
même ça couvre sans problème facilement
une année donc je pense qu'il faudra une
saison où l'état mais au cas par cas
ça va demander à être rapproché du
terrain par les services régionaux
puissent suivre les choses mais il y
aura besoin d'une saison accompagné pour
que l'on retrouve des équilibres ça se
prépare du côté de la majorité ça on
pense déjà à l'après conique une bonne
question que vous me posez vous êtes
mieux placé que je l'espère je l'espère
pour eux au juste que je sais qu rosine
dachau en tout cas connais bien
l'économie du spectacle fin on sait que
l aime la musique qu'ils aiment le
théâtre voilà donc cet aspect merci mais
beaucoup de gens a priori de
l'instantané sur la culture dire qu'on a
l'impression c'est pas des métiers n'y a
pas de formation ça s'apprend pas ça
sera ça là on arrive on fait le truc on
s'en va c'est pas du tout ça ce sont des
métiers qu'on apprend qu'on transmet con
con qu'on travaille c'est du travail
collectif qu'il faut assembler c'est de
la technique beaucoup c'est vrai et
ensuite c'est une véritable économie
comme ça vient d'être présent mais une
fois le spectacle produit dans un lieu
on essaye de le faire tourner pour le
partager mais aussi bien sûr pour lui
trouver des cofinancements ça au moins
elle connaît cette réalité de l'économie
du spectacle mais quand une question
très importante c'est que si les salles
peuvent se remplir complètement c'est à
dire que si les jours voir des choses
plein ça quand même ça aidera rapport au
fonctionnement le théâtre
parce que quand même moi je crois
beaucoup à une chose quand même
nous on est un vrai virus la culture
c'est le virus de la joie et il faut que
ce virus se répande énormément et les
gens en ont besoin
il ya un moment les gens ils vont venir
ils ont besoin comme on a besoin de
boire comme on use as quoi et ça c'est
quelque chose qui va non seulement faire
d'un député du fes de d'état de morale
qui va remonter mais surtout les
communes et économiquement ça va jouer
beaucoup et je crois que ça aussi c'est
un point important et vous avez tout à
fait raison de dire qu'il a un soutien
notamment dans tout les théâtres de
régions qui ont déjà à celle des
tournées etc pour que les tournées
puisse se faire parce que si son âge là
aussi ça va être difficile va être
compliqué la tournée aujourd'hui c'est
un élément constitutionnel de la
production y a pas un seul spectacle
seulement de dire on va s'en sortir en
faisant une exploitation normale à paris
à lyon ou à marseille c'est la tournée
qui pousse le but est le théâtre que
vous dirigez est en danger ou pas c
c'est à dire il est en danger à deux
endroits il est en danger les tendances
et d'abord parce que on devrait répéter
plein de gens ont fait des podcasts face
à il est en danger parce que je venais
que le plus un temps j'ai la chance
d'avoir une équipe extrêmement motivée
très autour de moi qui voit là c'est
leur histoire c'est leur vie et là il ya
un côté un tout petit peu quand même de
dépression on en a marre ils ont pu en
vivre on n'a plus envie de venir ça
c'était un premier point qui est non
négligeable parce que ça fait partie que
l'énergie de la création et la deuxième
chose c'est parce que à force de hannut
les spectacles reportés dans des
endroits actions dans mes moments des
sanctions déjà programmée il ya un
moment tout va s'écrouler
on est sans arrêt en train d'essayer de
faire du rubik's cube toute la journée
qu'à un moment ça marche on est tous
t'ont et des pièces qui ne se joueront
pas bien sûr il ya des pièces qui ne se
seront pas il ya des pièces qui sont
reportés seront 23
mais est-ce qu'on mène 3 les acteurs ont
envie de faire ça il ya des pièces qui
sont bouteille les unes sur les autres
il ya des pièces je citerai pas le nom
exact est très connue en larmes qui
montent
supplie si oui je veux bien mais qu'est
ce que c'est pas moi qui décide si oui
il ya une espèce au bout d'un moment les
espèces de névrose général d'affliction
est une espèce de sentiment de dire bon
bah c'est foutu on attendait on arrête
quoi et on va où on ne sait pas un
acteur metteur en scène un auteur les
auteurs n'ont aucune protection aucune
protection
les auteurs à part l'alsace aînés qui je
crois maintenant mais à son soutien qui
les aide mais les auteurs sont des gens
totalement démuni il n'y a pas de
chômage
il n'y a pas de l'intermittent du
spectacle et c'est quand même le pétrole
du théâtre ce qui importe et jean non
c'est vrai il ya un moment on va être à
plat et on pourra pas du jour au
lendemain
ouvrir un petit restaurant vous faire
une usine de radiateur et l'alerté
lancée ici sur ce plateau merci
infiniment à tous les quatre d'avoir
participer au grand débat lpl c'est donc
la fin de cette émission je vous
retrouve lundi à 18 heures et à 22
heures pour un nouveau numéro et puis
demain pour trouver bonjour chez vous
dès 7h30 comme tous les jours mais cette
fois attention matinale spéciale
délocalisé à toulouse au rayonnement de
chimie recevra notamment carole delga
qui est la présidente de la région
occitanie je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat